dinner right it's a daily grind the
frustration over what are you gonna cook
how long is it gonna take well many of
us are busier than ever but still
looking for quality in our personal
lives when it comes to good food we
caught up with the ceo and founder of
gobble about how the pandemic
accelerated her business
the company gobble was created out of
ushmagarg's own struggle to put
home-cooked meals on the table working
around the clock and relying on takeout
she and an executive chef came up with
the 15 minute one pan dinner kit high
quality meals offering cuisine from
around the world we are your sous chef
and we do all the nissan floss and the
prep work so that busy families can make
dinner in just 15 minutes in one pan the
company's direct to consumer model was
built to handle varying menus and an
agile supply chain what broke in the
traditional grocery store supply chains
you know
really carved that opportunity for
startups and the next generation of food
company to go direct and deliver in fact
ushma says even after the pandemic surge
her business is seeing 20 percent more
orders from existing members she says
they're more cognizant of less food
waste and getting a quality fresh meal
on the table tens of thousands of
families that were ordering pre pandemic
have changed their behavior and shifted
from the grocery store or shifted from
more take-out nights to
finding easy solutions to still
maintain some of that pandemic cooking
behavior now in this return to work new
normal
gobble has chefs stationed all across
the country who do the prep work and
ship overnight customers in 46 different
states